hello there the Hitman series received
an important update recently Hitman 3 is
no more and now in its place is Hitman
world of assassination combining the
entire Trilogy into one single game
those who own Hitman 3 you now own all
the maps from the previous two games
free of charge on top of that is a brand
new game mode to play which tasks Agent
47 with starting his own freelancer
service a deadly version of events in
which there are no game saves and should
we fail a mission all the weapons and
half the money on our person at the time
is gone it must all be earned back to
celebrate Hitman freelancer's release IO
interactive have challenged me to become
the world's greatest Hitman and I accept
oh and they gave me PlayStation codes to
give away after each successful mission
my first assignment sent me to Sapienza
to take out this bad guy highlighted in
red to my surprise he was in a public
area so I wasted no time I charged down
to the beach my plan was to stick him
with the poison and then run away before
anyone noticed easy right well no it
turns out there are guards everywhere in
this game mode and bad planning results
in this yikes I returned to the safe
house with wounds lessons had been
learned if you fail to prepare you
prepare to fail so I dedicated myself
and got a bit better at the game
again
my next assignment saw 47 sent to an
island Paradise Welcome to the Maldives
we have Intel that The Syndicate is
present in the area the task was to
eliminate an evil doctor and Escape
unseen by this point I'd learned a few
tricks such as these people with the
icon overhead they have money we can
take and here's a pro tip by bringing a
banana from your house and placing it in
their path forgive my excitement you
ready for this
they'll fall Head Over Heels allowing 47
to steal their cash and no one even
noticed it was just an accident my
target was locked up in his Waterside
home a quick Snoop around showed all
doors were closed and locked tight and
his personal assistant did not leave his
side I needed to think and thinking is
quite tough when there's a jet ski
riding around breaking my concentration
anyway long story short he's now
sleeping with the fishes
I'd thought about it I was ready to
fulfill my contract I had a plan I
noticed the doc's lady friend had a key
to the house and using my Superior
parkour skills I took that key when she
wasn't looking next I needed to take out
his PA as I was never gonna get close
enough to poison him without her
noticing so master plan part 2 I forced
the sink to overflow in the bathroom and
noticed a floor panel nearby I wonder
oh wow she fell through the trapdoor and
into the ocean nobody noticed so we're
in the clear I think let's crack on
finally I just had to wait until the
doctor was in his private room and no
one could notice and mission complete oh
wait that was a sedative
he's not on a live He's on awake so I
had to get a little more Hands-On with
this one and the mission was over a
frantic jog back to the dock and I was
in the clear I was officially a hitman
the next flight took me to China and
Chongqing oh by the way in the top
Corner are optional quests which award
us additional money if we do them
successfully the yellow one is a
Prestige assignment which we get to
select ourselves and I chose to kill a
target with a freaking shuriken as the
rain pod I took to the rooftops to
survey the city and completely lucked
out as one of my targets was right here
I had to use a sedative on him before I
could turn off his lights forever thanks
to the poor visibility I was able to
sneak up and do the deed deep Behind
Enemy Lines 1.5 Grand in the bank the
next two opportunities were perfect for
me pacify guard without them noticing
and then hiding their bodies I used a
cheeky fuse box switch to lure out
guards one by one and then hugged them
to sleep finding places to hide their
bodies was the hard bit done and done
two down two to go but this one was
going to be hard hidden away in the city
is a super secret facility under the
ground the weigh-in is far too guarded
so I stocked the area after stealing
this guy's threads I followed a cook
walking down an Alleyway what was she
doing and wow she led me into the base
oh and this leads to a skill on every
Mission we have access to a camera which
can hack certain doors I couldn't wait
to use it and I made my first mistake of
this run the cook knew I was up to no
good and followed me shouting I may have
panicked and accidentally heard her
before running away
to make up for it I switched professions
and became a cook if you're wearing the
right attire you can get almost anywhere
scanning all body systems getting
through biometric health check was a
little scary but in the end the AI gave
me a compliment to ease my worries
you're very fit to perform cheers
darling progress to my final Target was
finally halted a security door I could
not get through I needed another master
plan so I dropped a gun outside the door
and waited for a guard to notice it
inside as he opened the door I slipped
in genius but I'm also a fool because I
couldn't resist a man in uniform and I
had to try it on myself and I got stuck
outside again yikes so I went the other
way instead and found a hackable door
leading to my target the problem was
he's an elite guard in a room full of
elite guards there is no way I could
take him out with a throwing star
without being spotted luckily NPCs can't
resist an overflowing sink and as he
came to fix the issue he met the pointy
end of foreign
this is my last body to hide for a
perfect run of all four objectives I
slipped out and went back home on a
scooter like a true badass
back at our safe house we unlock Mastery
ranks which let 47 upgrade and evolve
his home like unlocking a freaking
motorbike off earth to travel to Future
contracts each room offers a new item
for 47 to take with him for example
there's a stethoscope which can double
as a Fiber Wire there's a golf club on
the roof if you want that there's a
poison mushroom in the garden and of
course you know my favorite item is the
banana there are creative ways to take
out targets hidden all around us
in the basement all the weapons we've
brought home from successful missions
can be added to our collection and used
in future missions which will be
imperative for the next type of activity
Showdown missions these are extra tough
instead of red targets they become
purple as we don't know which one is the
correct person to take out we've got to
do our own reconnaissance using our
camera we can get close enough to check
off tells such as hairstyle tattoos if
they're wearing a necklace and what
habits to look out for and then after
following them round for long enough you
identify the right target getting it
wrong could result in the real Target
escaping so the pressure is on I took my
chance I hit my shot and it paid off
the leader is eliminated Syndicate
defeated Hitman freelancer completely
changes the series the potential to lose
equipment is petrifying and I love it
picking off the perfect snipe under
pressure and getting away unnoticed
feels absolutely epic if you'd like to
find out more about Hitman and the new
game mode freelancer click the link in
the description I'm Adam you're awesome
a huge thank you to IO interactive for
sponsoring this video and supplying
codes I'd love to make more Hitman
content please let me know your thoughts
in the comments I'll see you soon
[Music]
bananas legit the greatest weapon in the
Arsenal